isn't it crazy this dude's never played
video games really he's wild wild I
think he's lived it real life I think I
was playing around I played GTA in like
the front yard
[Music]
all right guys the reviews are in
Facebook's metaverse has been out for
quite some time now really no how long
like out as in like out or like out like
hey like people oh you see that's that's
a problem if we didn't know no one's
playing on that [ __ ] anymore because
crypto crashed so hard it's not a hot
show guys no
um it is officially a sad and empty
unpopular flop wow imagine all the
people that paid like hundreds of
thousands for like real estate in the
metaverse dude yeah you don't think it's
gonna
I think so I bought I bought um what's
known as the Inland Empire on meta just
so I can create a like a Atlanta just
strip clubs
should have called the skinlin Empire
somewhere in there that was good oh in
that particular myth I don't know so
like
dive into the don't ask him questions
yeah Ryan yeah so there's worlds within
worlds and like Horizon worlds is one of
the main ones and it's just nobody's
[ __ ] using it dude where's Snoop Dogg
what's not a big thing that Snoop Dogg
bought some [ __ ] he bought land as well
but that was in like the sand one yeah
the sandbox yeah that's not this that
ain't so different so when you go to the
metaverse like what is the appeal
you're asking that at this point yeah
because I still and it's not because
like I'm [ __ ] on it I just don't
know what the purpose of it is have you
seen Ready Player one yeah so that's
what they're trying to build
so that's what they're trying to build
right I could be a condom
spoiler I'm about to be a hot [ __ ]
anime girl yeah
it's too hard to get into it right like
first you have to [ __ ] have an Oculus
which is expensive and clunky I got one
two when you put it on how comfortable
is that right it's like it's not simple
it's a little top heavy when you talk
about like accessing the metaverse until
it's like this easy yeah like how are
you gonna get the [ __ ] whole world on
it you know what I'm saying like if you
have to plug in every single time put on
this thing that's gonna [ __ ] give you
a headache and hold these [ __ ] weird
ass things and try and communicate with
stuff and point to stuff without control
it's like it's not going to be super
adopted you know right away but
at the same time though later on totally
possible right because then you look at
things it's always about timing and just
the right uh time look at like [ __ ]
the app Clubhouse when the pandemic
happened blew the [ __ ] up and then once
it's like you go back to regular World
nobody's a [ __ ] about it you know what
I'm saying so you can also blow up right
away and not work this one maybe is just
like the Long play right eventually the
future makes sense for us to like
digitize in so many ways so it kind of
still makes sense but in the current if
you can't [ __ ] get everybody to like
adopt it it's of course I think I think
people are gonna find new ways for
escapism I mean people already do that
nowadays so I think the Long Haul could
be quite possible because people might
be so bored with their current state of
how they choose to explore escapism
um some people do drugs whatever so the
metaverse could be like that form of
escapism for people are you saying that
in a positive way uh no I say some
people can use this Escape ISM for
positive or negative it's a tool yeah I
think so
it depends could it be that it's not
working because like 90 but the
characters are are women
oh I haven't even looked I don't even
know this character because if you think
about like like women
these are totally broad assumptions but
like women I feel like they're
characters are women but men there's a
lot they'll just be women that's true
you know what I mean like when they sign
up for things that makes sense yeah and
then when they get in there it's like
dude everyone's a girl in here like well
this is stupid like the 10 that are guys
I don't get it yeah because if there's
90 women yeah and I'm rolling around in
there that sounds like a good thing but
if they're not actually women but
everyone else it's like it's like that
Black Mirror episode oh no yeah that's
still fun though because that's a
different life yeah yeah that's VR mic
yeah
what happens in VR stays in VR yeah no
that's cool oh that's true what if you
if you hook up with a dude on on uh yeah
you're playing so does that make you a
break dancer or not I don't know don't
be giving it away so fast I could be a
break dancer in there right yeah
so I'll try out in there yeah you can
try out different occupations you could
be a welder in there you can beat
breakdancer out here honestly
occupations
so this is this is Michael this has
always been my qualm about it is I think
a lot of people that were showing all
this enthusiasm for it and projecting
that it's going to be the next big thing
and and even they're saying they're
gonna use it all the time I don't even
think those are the people that even
really play games that long I think in
order to really want to do something
like this for a long time you kind of
already have to be in the Wheelhouse of
doing this type of thing for fun already
yeah have you seen extreme VR I've
watched some streamers play some crazy
stuff and it's yeah you're right the
accessibility is crazy expensive but
they'll get a little hectic feedback
deals all over their body those and
they'll be doing some stuff like you
know like what what stuff right here
yeah hectic feedback's like when your
phone buzzes when you type it okay right
so you put some senses on your body I
know like a lot of little shits but I'm
not that smart but it's like usually
like for example the way it works really
dope in like a a controller on a console
yeah is if I'm pushing the trigger
button for a gun it's going to give me
feedback relative to that isn't it crazy
this dude's never play video games
really he's wild wild I think he's lived
in real life I think I was playing
around I played GTA in like the front
yard
example of
um why people kind of just scoffed or
laughed at the idea of this because uh
GTA has been around forever and that in
itself is probably the most complex
metaverse that it even exists and there
are micro transactions and there are
people making money and there are
exchanges and it's very it's like it has
its own economy it had its own stock
market in the single player game but the
main thing is that people don't pay
attention to it because they don't play
that but yet metaverse comes out and
they think it's this big thing and
they're like oh it's going to be this
and that it's like you don't even like
or are interested in GTA which probably
is what metaverse would someday wish to
be so so is the problem with metaverse
right now is that it's just not enough
options and just not enough things that
are built out I think a lot of people
are are hesitant to admit that they were
more interested in the financial outcome
of the metaverse than actually [ __ ]
playing it then actually interacting
with us then it was also during a much
more extreme time though right like see
like everything that we've been through
in the last like three years has been
very [ __ ] extreme so imagine like all
the crazy you have about the metaverse
was also a time where people around the
world were stuck the [ __ ] in their homes
they couldn't do stuff right so so the
actual appeal of it made so much sense
because that was like 50 of your options
going into the digital world then
suddenly you [ __ ] go back out and do
everything you can go back and self-eye
Stadium like 600 000 people without
Master where the [ __ ] it's like who
gives a [ __ ] about my VR world today you
know what I mean hey don't say that dude
I love my audio it was like a uh it was
like a launch in a marketing scheme too
right because Facebook changed their
name to meta as the metaverse became
like its own and web three even became
like in our regular daily dialogue so it
was kind of just like an album launch
and then the album just didn't really
make it it flopped yeah but then Part
Two Is Gonna Come And once we're hectic
feedback [ __ ] everywhere but like right
I think horns industry is probably
killing it in the that world yeah I
think porn industry's killing it in
every world that's that's true yeah
they're killing it no matter what
they're an anomaly there are some games
on the Oculus where you're like dude
this is too sick but like you said it
doesn't outweigh the amount of setup
that you need to actually play well yeah
because but I don't think it's Nintendo
yet yeah it's like not even Nintendo yet
you know we I don't know if you guys
game at all but we're on like PC games
you compare that to Nintendo crazy I
think we're not even at Nintendo in
terms of what that technology can do so
when the technology and the
accessibility level dude your timeline's
[ __ ]
on the gun she's like after Nintendo
if I if I were to be excited about it I
think the next uh major level comes with
the next major like uh rewiring of
Hardware like everybody's super stoked
on like apple when the [ __ ] are you
finally gonna get into AR VR right the
Apple glasses have been ruined for
literally like two three years and
they're talking about it everybody's
doing this thing we're like oh this guy
credible Source leaked it you're
starting to see cool stuff but ideally
right when you think about the idea of
something like light glasses like that
size actual glasses that you can put on
and there's also an AR component so
you're not just constantly stuck in this
digital place that gives you [ __ ]
vertigo augmented reality yeah yeah
assault rifles
um and then um right but then the second
the second you can actually use it in
real world because it's light it's got
long battery life you can you can see
regular [ __ ] you can click a button to
go back into like virtual that's when
that user functionality can transcend
like putting a 16 pound thing on your
head right the convenience you know what
I mean I'm waiting for the Minority
Report close wow oh yeah
[Laughter]
I think it's it's an interesting thing
because it's I think marketers are so
[ __ ] good that they were able to
figure out quicker how to get people to
spend money on something better than
they were figuring out how to get them
to spend the time and I think that's
ultimately when you make something and
everybody buys real estate in it but no
one's using it that's how you know you
were good at this and not the other and
that's a hard thing to do because like
again like gaming in general just has a
big problem with battling the balance of
microtransactions and actual gameplay so
a lot of people want to earn things by
being good at something and then other
people want to expedite it by just
paying for it but then those two things
you can't have at the same time we ain't
doing that because one ruins for the
other exactly we grind for our [ __ ]
exactly I think they also overestimated
how many introverts there are
yeah because I think you know like you
were saying like for three years we're
stuck at home we didn't really do much
and the clubhouse blew up and all the
other day this is a great time
everyone's you know forcefully being
introverted but then once things started
opening back up the extroverts and like
the mid the mid people were like I'm not
staying home like I'm gonna go out yeah
well timing plays a big role in that
yeah
so I think they overestimated like how
many people are gonna like be cool
staying home on their computers or on
their Oculus and like living in that
like digital world as opposed to going
out and meeting people face to face
right uh because that's I think face to
face there's always gonna be people that
want to do face to face like the
extroverts are the mid people but the
introverts like the extreme introvers
always want to stay home so they're the
ones that are going to pay for the the
Oculus the haptic the feedback all that
because for them that's their world but
I don't think there's they don't even
represent like a minority it's like a
minority like a minute very very niche
in the niche Niche yeah but what do you
what about when Tech is more one-to-one
with reality then yeah so for me right I
think it's a more of a tech
accessibility issue than a than a human
issue because once we're like one
percent of reality yeah but once it's
like 80 and now you can [ __ ] fly
right the Curiosity alone is just gonna
drag people for me I think it's when sex
robots get to the point where you can
you can have it right you guys remember
that scene in the movies um there's a
Serenity of Serenity when Nathan I mean
it was based on this TV show Firefly
David krumholtz his character was just
in his room and he had three sex dolls
that walked around and talked to him
once we get to a point near there I
think then people just got just to stay
home like in Japan and Korea where um
the birth rate is going down it's
decreasing it's declining every year
because people aren't getting married
they're just staying home and gaming for
those guys if they're making money at
home they don't have to leave all the
foods delivered and they have a sex
robot that has AI That's decent AI can
talk to them has haptic feedback
actually touches them there's no reason
for them to leave that's when I think
meta starts blowing up more and women
become extinct yeah that's what that's
what we need to pitch to Mark Zuckerberg
be like yo you need to [ __ ] get on
your sex robot advancing and then from
there meta is going to work we talked
about AI though what was that
um Elon Musk talked about Ai and about
his fear for having AI being put in the
wrong hands oh of course I mean I mean
that alone so yeah but all they need is
basic AI for a second because guys we
don't want deep conversations right
that's true you just want them to say
yes yeah as long as they say yes like
we're good with that continued learning
on [ __ ] skills yes so you're saying
that it's not a Silicon Valley issue
it's a matter of Boston Dynamics yes
[Music]
[Music]